for people who aren't disciplined are  there suggestions to increase your  ability to become disciplined yeah but  nobody likes them wake up early no one  wants to do that but i think it's a good  cornerstone for discipline because it  kind of gets your day off on the right  foot and i can just about guarantee you  that if you wake up early and you do  some exercise you'll feel better for the  rest of the day and hopefully when you  get to the end of that day you're a  little bit more tired earlier which  means you go to bed earlier which means  it's a little easier to wake up early  the next day and then you do some  exercise that day and you feel good  again and then at the end of that day  you're even a little bit more tired even  a little bit earlier so instead of  staying up until two o'clock in the  morning on watching netflix you're going  to bed at a normal time and waking up  early